president Trump had very big issues on
trade that he wanted to get to with
China you know he felt like China their
Trade Practices were unfair they weren't
following all the global rules of trade
uh he was a little bit nervous that they
would be provocative with Taiwan and I
felt like the two of them getting
together would be the best way to try
and resolve that so um the Chinese are
very proud and a lot of it is about face
and so we in order to negotiate for that
first call we we basically agreed on
what would happen in the call so not
let's just have a call say hi nice to
meet you was a question of President
Trump basically agreed that he would
acknowledge the one China policy which
he didn't see as a big concession
because you could always unacknowledged
the next day so yeah I'll acknowledge it
and then we'll go and exchange uh
president shei was going to come over to
the US for a visit so they could sit
together and they wanted to do it
outside the White House and so we agreed
on MAR logo which I also thought was
good because president Trump always felt
much more comfortable when he was
hosting uh at his properties and he just
felt at home and so he liked having
people as his guests and he loved he
loved it he always felt really relaxed
and and it was great so that was really
what we did then the Chinese come over
very much anticipated visit and it was
incredible so they were supposed to sit
together for 15 minutes uh and um they
sent about an hour and a half together
and during that meeting President Trump
they said look let's just set some
ground rules to this relationship like
let's just not talk about Taiwan like
you know just don't do anything I don't
want on the table if it does I'm going
to have to do harsh things I don't want
this to be a problem for four years we
got bigger issues they basically just
again you notice four years of trump
Administration no Taiwan talk whatsoever
it was a non-issue started talking about
the trade issues they spent a lot of
time on North Korea uh president Trump
was trying to get the perspective from
uh from president XI about North Korea
because that was again considered from
Obama the biggest national security
issue that we faced at the time and um
and they just had a good feeling for
each other it also helped that you know
uh my wife and I we actually had had a a
Chinese uh Nanny and teacher in our
house and our our kids learned fluent
Mandarin and our daughter actually
opened uh when uh president she and
president Trump were together with h
with Melania and with uh Madame Pang is
is um uh my daughter actually sang them
a couple of Chinese songs and uh and I
thought that was a nice way to show you
know we're tough but we respect your
culture because the Chinese have an
incredible culture that goes back
thousands of years they're very proud
and in how um and how they do it and I
think that sign of respect ALS set
things off in a very warm way for
president Trump to say my granddaughter
speaks Chinese and and we're showing you
the respect um which I think is very
important and he did have respect for
them the next part about the visit I
mean obviously we had a lot of
discussions on trade but the part that
was probably most impactful to me was
President XI basically did an hour
monologue uh at lunch where he just went
through uh Chinese history from his
perspective and he talked about U with
particular
emphasis on on kind of the Treaty of
unequals and then the 100 Years of
humiliation and then you go through from
ma all the way to today and you had you
know China coming back and rising and
you could tell that he was learned the
lessons from the past and was very
committed to kind of seeing China go
through so that was a different time
right so China today is different than
it was in
that